We've seen how to use integer variables to store and keep track of numbers.
Another very popular type of variables in Java is the string variable.
A string variable is used to store names,
words or even whole sentences.
Basically anything that's made up of characters.
In Java, a character is a single alphabetical letter or digit or even a symbol like
the dollar sign or a hash or a at
pretty much anything that you can use when you're creating a password for example.
So, if you want to store a phrase or a word that's made up of those characters,
you should use a string variable.
That's where the name string comes from,
being like a string connecting bunch of characters like this.
Let's say we wanted to store the bus driver's name in a variable.
We first need to declare that string variable and give it a name,
just like we did with declaring integers.
We start by typing in the variable type which in this case is
a string and then the variable name which is something that we come up with.
In this case, I call it driver.
This declaration statement is like as if we've
created this empty box that can store a string inside,
but remember it can only store strings from now on not integers,
not anything else just strings.
So, the next thing we need to do is initialize it.
Notice that I've surrounded this string here with quotation marks.
Remember when, I used them earlier with the print line.
This basically means we're referring to the word Hamish,
literally, not a variable called Hamish.
That's why this is called a string literal.
This initialization fills our box with the word Hamish.
Notice that if, I didn't put the quotation marks
here the computer would think that this is
a variable called Hamish and would try to
find it and would go crazy when it couldn't find it.
But now since we have this new variable driver and it has the word Hamish in it,
there's actually a lot that Java can do.
String variables are really cool variables:
it can count the number of letters in the string,
it can change the string to
all capital letters and it can do a lot more that we're going to see later on.
Let's start by programming the computer to count the letters in the string.
For that we can use
the length command that's written as length and then empty parentheses here.
This instruction here would count the number of letters
inside the variable driver not the word driver itself,
but whatever is stored inside that variable,
but we need to store that number in a variable since letter counts are
just natural numbers we can use an integer for that.
Now that we've stored the number of letters
in the word Hamish inside their variable letters,
let's print out the variable letters and see what it displays.
If we run that program the print output would be six,
which is exactly the number of characters inside that string here.
Perfect. Let's see if we wanted to change something in
the string like update every character to become a capital letter.
For that we can use the command toUpperCase.
Again, it's just a string variable dot,
this operation to uppercase followed by empty parentheses,
but we need to store that into our string variable driver.
So, we're basically telling our computer program to update
the variable driver to be equal to whatever the old driver variable was,
but uppercasing every single letter,
making it a capital letter.
So, let's print out our variable driver to see what happened to it.
Once we were run this program this is the output that we get.
It's exactly the same string but every letter is now a capital letter.
Thanks to this command toUpperCase.
There's another one called toLowerCase which
obviously does the opposite and there's more.
We'll learn a lot more about strings and what we can do with them later on,
but next let's have a look at
another cool thing we can do with strings called concatenation.